nos dicen que el triángulo a prima de
prima se prima que es este triángulo de
color rojo es la imagen del triángulo
abc que es este triángulo azul bajo la
rotación respecto al origen
entonces la rotación es respecto al
origen que tenemos aquí determina el
ángulo de rotación como siempre pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver bien
pensemos en cómo es que cada uno de
estos puntos es rotado para pasar de a a
a- prima o de b a b prima o se hace
prima empecemos con aquí empieza el
punto a y recuerden que rotamos a partir
del origen por eso he dibujado esta
línea desde el origen hasta a ahora
hacia donde rota bueno como es rotado
hacia acá la rotación va en el sentido
contrario de las manecillas del reloj
por lo que será un ángulo positivo así
que podemos cancelar estos dos ángulos
pregunta clave es serán 30 grados o 60
grados bueno hay muchas formas en las
que podemos analizarlo una es que 60
grados equivalen a dos tercios de un
ángulo recto mientras que 30 grados son
solamente un tercio y miren un ángulo
recto sería así entonces esto se parece
más a dos tercios del ángulo recto así
que estos son 60 grados
otra forma de pensarlo es que 60 grados
equivalen a un tercio de 180 grados que
también lo podemos ver aquí y si hacemos
eso con cualquiera de estos puntos
veremos lo mismo así que al analizar la
rotación de a prima podemos decir que
fue una rotación de 60 grados hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nos dice el
cuadrilátero a prima de prima se prima
de prima que es el de color rojo es la
imagen del cuadrilátero
abc de que es de color azul bajo
una rotación respecto al punto que
determina el ángulo de rotación
nuevamente pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolver bueno vamos a abordarlo
de la misma forma aquí no tenemos un
plano coordinado pero es la misma noción
podemos tomar cualquier punto inicial y
después observar su imagen para analizar
cuánto necesitamos rotarla por ejemplo
podríamos analizar de b a b prima aunque
se encuentran muy cerca usaré otro color
vamos a ver cómo es que pasamos de b a b
prima miren aquí vamos en el sentido de
las manecillas del reloj así que será
una rotación negativa y podemos cancelar
estos dos ahora bien esto se parece a un
ángulo recto verdad entonces podemos
decir que el ángulo de rotación es de
menos 90 grados y podemos intentar con
otro punto para corroborar que son menos
90 grados veamos qué pasa del punto de a
de prima aquí es donde se encuentra d
y aquí es donde se encuentra de prima
nuevamente las rotaciones en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj así que es
una rotación negativa y esto también se
parece a un ángulo recto definitivamente
se parece más a un ángulo recto que a
uno de 60 grados así que la rotación es
de menos 90 grados esta parece ser una
mejor respuesta hemos terminado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo